salut j'ai décidé d'appeler cette vidéo
l'arnaqué du siècle parce que j'ai
sincèrement l'impression que la grande
majorité d'entre nous se fait avoir par
une espèce d'entourloupe une entourloupe
prix je veux dire est un mensonge une
illusion une croyance a fondé un tour de
passe-passe qui entretient une situation
mal à net déséquilibre et j'en ai parlé
brièvement dans un format court et
j'avais promis qu'on s'y penche serait
un peu plus longuement la mecque du
siècle c'est l'idée de mérite et parce
qu'une entourloupe d'une telle ampleur
comporte évidemment des ramifications
complexes cette vidéo est conçu en
coopération avec la chaîne patchwork qui
sort en même temps sa propre vidéo sur
un aspect de la question
alors commençons par une expression
c'est mérité on dit c'est mérité aussi
bien pour les récompenses que pour les
punitions l'idée qui se cache derrière
c'est donc un comportement a entraîné
pour son auteur de juste conséquence
c'est mérité ici cela veut dire il n'y a
pas d'injustice est d'emblée on voit ce
que la notion de mérite comporte de
politique il est sans doute impossible
de penser la notion de mérite
indépendamment de la notion de justice
on n'imaginerait pas déclaré qu'une
chose soit à la fois mérité et injuste
mais alors un énorme problème se pose
immédiatement sur quelle conception de
la justice la notion de mérite est elle
fondée bien évidemment il faut que nous
évitions le raisonnement circulaire
autant que possible ceux qui jugent ses
skis mérité et ce qui m'était c'est ce
qui est juste on n'arrête pas bien
avancé c'est donc notre première enquête
quelle idée de justice se cache derrière
la notion de mérite
mon intuition c'est que l'idée de
justice qui fondent le mérite est une
notion qui se présente comme naturelle
par là j'entends qu'elle ne se présente
pas comme arbitraire au fond cette idée
de justice c'est aussi un sentiment de
justice le sentiment que ceci est juste
ou injuste et ce sentiment il se déclare
en nous comme une évidence plutôt que
comme une décision bon là je suis un peu
trop abstrait alors je vais essayer de
donner un exemple imaginer un jeu dans
ce jeu le but est d'obtenir des jetons
de couleurs il ya les rouges les bleus
les verts etc les joueurs passent par
toute une série d'énigmes et de défis
pour obtenir ses jetons et chacun se
retrouve au bout d'un moment avec une
certaine somme de rouge de bleu de vert
etc
maintenant imaginons deux variantes dans
la première les couleurs sont associés à
un niveau de difficulté et à un nombre
de points pour obtenir un verre il faut
résoudre une énigme difficile et cela
vaut 50 points alors que pour le rouge
le dévier simple et cela vaut cinq
points à la fin du jeu celui ou celle
qui a le plus de points l'emportent dans
la seconde variante à chaque fois qu'un
joueur réussi le défi ou l'énigme on
lance un dé et la face sur lequel il
tombe détermine nombre de points
attribués aux joueurs une alarme
retentit aléatoirement et décrète la fin
du jeu le vainqueur final est celui qui
a le plus de points
le second jeu et il injuste en un sens
pas du tout les joueuses et les joueurs
connaissent la règle avant d'y
participer de la même manière qu'un jeu
de hasard comme la roulette ou une
machine à sou n'est pas injuste mais en
un sens on a l'intuition que quelque
chose ne va pas d'enjeu qu'il ya une
forme d'injustice peut-être qu'une
joueuse qui aurait réussi les énigmes
les plus difficiles aurait eu peu de
points à cause du dea et vice versa et
ça ça parait étrange parce que le jeu
implique les compétences des joueurs et
des joueuses l'introduction du hasard
s'en [ __ ] par terre la possibilité
d'une justice dans la seconde variante
on aurait du mal à dire que le vainqueur
mérite sa victoire c'est donc là où je
voulais en venir dans la seconde
variante on a affaire à une justice
arbitraire c'est la règle du jeu c'est
aléatoire imprévisible mais c'est ainsi
c'est ce qu'on a décidé de faire la
justice dans un tel cas c'est que le
joueur ou la joueuse qui a le plus de
points sera déclarée vainqueur et puis
c'est tout
en un sens c'est pas si les tran si on
gagne à la machine à sous on considère
qu'il est juste qu'on reparte avec les
gains en jeu c'est normal c'est le sens
du contrat compass tacitement avec le
casino mais pour autant on ne dirais pas
qu'on a mérité d'avoir gagné le premier
jeu en revanche nous donne l'impression
d'être fondamentalement juste les
récompenses sont proportionnelles à la
difficulté donc à la compétence requise
celui ou celle qui gagne ce sera le ou
la meilleur tout simplement ce sera
juste et méritée et j'irai même plus
loin ce sera logique je crois que pour
la plupart d'entre nous cette justice là
elle paraît logique c'est en ce sens que
je parlais de justice naturelle c'est
pour ça qu'on lance que le meilleur
gagne
en récompensant les efforts et les
compétences on semble s'inscrire dans
une logique naturelle le meilleur les
plus compétentes doit l'emporter et ça
nous semble normal un jeu une
compétition c'est là pour se mettre à
l'épreuve pour se tester se comparer
s'affronter c'est face à l'adversité
qu'on progresse etc etc on connaît le
refrain ce serait ça la justice
naturelle celle qui récompense les
meilleurs du coup vous voyez le problème
le couple méritent justice déborde le
seul cadre des jeux et des compétitions
sportives pour affecter la société dans
son ensemble
en quel sens peut-on dire que la société
est une compétition qu'est ce qui nous
incite à la voir comme ça le premier
truc qui vient à l'esprit c'est
l'organisation de l'enseignement de la
notation des primaires au classement des
universités et grandes écoles en passant
par les épreuves sanctionnant comme le
bac les institutions scolaires semble
conçu selon un unique modèle à trois
manches 1 instruction de différentes
compétences techniques de valorisation
de ses compétences en fonction
d'objectifs donné
trois évaluations de la maîtrise des
dites compétences par l'élève
de sorte qu'une grille d'évaluation
objective semble émerger aux yeux des
élèves
mieux vaut être bon en maths ainsi tout
au long du parcours scolaire l'individu
se fait une idée des compétences qu'ils
valent mieux que d'autres et qui
logiquement impliquerait plus de mérite
de la même manière les sprinteurs sont
davantage célébré que les marathoniens
les joueuses de tennis que les joueuses
de badminton
certain talent sont davantage valorisés
et des individus sont classés comme en
fonction
il serait super intéressant de se
pencher sur les limites de l'évaluation
scolaire notamment à cause de la
standardisation des compétences qu'elle
implique mais ce serait un trop long
détour toujours est il qu'on peut voir
la société comme une compétition de
manière plus large encore on pourrait
dire qu'il y a des grandes tendances
désirante qui permettent d'identifier
explicitement ou implicitement des
gagnants ou des perdants
grosso modo beaucoup de gens s'accordent
à dire qu'il vaut mieux être riche que
pauvre célèbre gamme à nîmes qui vaut
mieux avoir du pouvoir être en bonne
santé à attendait cette histoire de
bonne santé révèle quelque chose oui
tout le monde est d'accord pour dire
qu'il vaut mieux être en bonne santé que
madame mais il ne nous arrivera jamais
de dire que telle personne mérite d'être
en bonne santé et que tel autre mérite
d'être malade on ne dirait pas qu'il est
juste que monsieur qu'il soit malade ou
clé injuste comme dame y soient en bonne
santé je dis jamais mais en vérité cela
arrive parfois précisément quand les
gens ont l'impression que la maladie en
question est de la responsabilité du mal
à il n'aurait pas dû fumer authentique
arrête elle n'aurait pas dû boire ils
auraient dû faire un régime etc
comme on le voit dans le livre de denis
colombie ou à l'argent des pauvres il
existe tout un discours pour faire des
pauvres les responsables de leur
pauvreté il serait pauvre parce qu'ils
font n'importe quoi avec leur argent
et les riches très riches car ils savent
gérer leur argent le niveau de richesse
serait une affaire de compétence spoiler
en vrai c'est pas du tout le cas et avec
cette insistance sur le thème de la
compétence on voit se dessiner deux
notions en creux qui explique l'armature
de la société compétition ces deux
notions sont intimement liés c'est
l'effort et le libre arbitre
ces deux notions combiné d'un lieu à
l'éthique de travail le raisonnement est
logique si l'être humain est libre alors
il est responsable de ses décisions si
les responsables ces décisions s'il est
libre de choisir entre se mettre au
travail et glander ou faire la fête
alors on va être tenté de le juger en
fonction de la quantité d'efforts qu'il
produit et cela nous conduit aussi à
projeter une équivalence entre réussite
et quantité d'efforts fournis celui qui
réussit donc celui qui se trouve plutôt
du côté des gagnants de la compétition
sociale on sera tenté de penser que
c'est parce qu'il a bossé pour c'est
l'idée qu'on est l'auteur de son succès
et ça vient de l'idée qu'on est
responsable de soi même de ce qu'on fait
plus concret aux produits c'est une
croyance qui est très avantageuse pour
l'individu qui a réussi au fond quand on
lui demande d'expliquer son succès il
peut répondre c'est du boulot mon vieux
et en disant ça le message qu'on essaie
de transmettre essentiellement c'est je
ne dois rien à personne
laissé entendre que notre succès est
mérité et donc ne doit rien à personne
c'est dire en somme qu'il n'y a rien
d'injuste dans notre succès
foucault à une expression bien trouver
entrepreneurs de soi être dans le
business de soi même cela définit bien
le sujet néolibérale qui cherche
constamment à exploiter son potentiel
qui se construit comme on monte une
entreprise avec des objectifs qui
cherchent à rentabiliser son temps mais
bon si je me lance dans le développement
personnel j'en ai pour une heure de plus
c'est du boulot mon vieux cela revient à
dire ne soyez pas jaloux de mon succès
comme s'il était dû à la chance foyer
plutôt admiratif de ma personne je
n'osais pas ma réussite jalousé plutôt
ce que je suis
et c'est peut-être pour cela d'ailleurs
que même celles et ceux qui ne
réussissent pas particulièrement
s'accroche à l'idée de mérite parce que
le mérite serait l indice de ce que nous
valons de nos qualités individuelles
voilà mon pari psychologique on donne
une place au mérite dans nos vies parce
qu'on ressent un fort besoin de savoir
si on est bon ou pas on est prêt à
avaler beaucoup de choses pour
l'opportunité d'obtenir un feedback sur
ce que nous valons et donc sur ce que
nous sommes encore une fois je sais que
j'insiste beaucoup là-dessus dans mes
vidéos mais ça me semble vraiment
centrale le besoin narcissique pourrait
jouer un rôle important dans la fonction
accordée au mérite parce que nous
voulons savoir qui nous sommes et les
critères de réussite ou d'échec peut
jouer le rôle de miroir le moyen par
lequel on parvient à s'observer
s'étudier se connaître l'elite sur
instagram les followers sur twitter la
compétition sportive toutes ces
informations nous permettent de nous
situer de nous faire une idée de ce que
nous sommes
nietzsche énoncé ainsi la maxime du
nihilisme plutôt vouloir le rien que de
ne rien vouloir en continuité on
pourrait dire mieux vaut souffrir de ses
échecs que d'abandonner toute
possibilité de succès plutôt se sentir
nul que d'abord donner la possibilité de
se sentir bon ou autrement dit plutôt
souffrir que de ne pas savoir ce qu'on
vaut il est tentant de regarder nos
activités comme autant de manières de
chercher à répondre à la question qui
suis-je l'idée mérite nous permet de
constituer une image plus ou moins
consciente de ce que nous valons et donc
de ce que nous sommes d'où cette
insistance pour faire du travail et de
l'effort les composantes essentielles de
la réussite car dans l'imaginaire
collectif plus la réussite tient un
talent inné on y lit à de mérite et puis
il est difficile de s'approprier le
succès l'idée dit n'est pas
explicitement vers la chance on parle
d'ailleurs de loterie génétique on fait
comme si une personne était constitué de
deux grandes familles de choses hein les
caractéristiques dont on ne serait pas
responsable ce qui englobe l'ensemble de
ce qu'on hérite
et puis ce qui nous tombe dessus par le
fait du hasard
la plupart des gens se refuse à juger
une personne sur la base de ces
caractéristiques là et ça paraît plutôt
sensée et puis il y aurait des
caractéristiques dont on serait
responsable ce qui renvoie implicitement
caractéristiques qu'on choisit de
développer c'est à dire au fond qu'on
décide d'être c'est grosso modo ce qu'on
appelle la personnalité et il arrive
qu'on juge les gens sur cette base on le
voit par exemple avec deux regards qui
peut être portée sur les alcooliques ou
des drogués voir avec les sdf il serait
responsable de leur déchéance car ils
auraient décidé de se droguer ou parce
qu'ils auraient choisi une vie en marge
de la société
comme on disait avec denis colombie on
aime bien imaginer les pauvres
responsables de leur pauvreté
il nous paraît plus légitime de juger
quelqu'un sur son caractère que ce son
lieu de naissance car nous considérons
qu'il est responsable du premier et non
du second mais rien ne prouve que nous
sommes responsables de notre
personnalité n'est ce pas celui qui
tient aux tripes pour responsable de ce
qu'il est ce qu'il croit il ressent qui
doit approuver une telle responsabilité
est il possible de responsabiliser
socialement et légalement les individus
c'est à dire d'inciter à des
comportements qu'on estime bénéfique
pour la société il ya des lois ou des
normes sociales tout en les
responsabilisant moralement c'est à dire
tout en considérant que l'individu
lui-même n'étant pas l'auteur de sa
propre personne n'est pour rien dans son
comportement
sans doute est il impossible de répondre
définitivement à cette question et je ne
vais pas me lancer là dedans mais je
vous propose d'y réfléchir aussi c'est
une problématique super vertigineuse
comment articuler ce que l'on découvre
autour du déterminisme aux normes
sociales à l'organisation de la société
bref s'il est si difficile de voir les
choses ainsi c'est d'abord parce que
nous jugeons nous mêmes comme si nous
étions les auteurs de notre propre
personnalité nous avons intimement
l'impression que nous prenons des
décisions libre et que par conséquent
nous sommes responsables de nos choix et
cela vient à mon avis une confusion
autour de la décision et de l'action
on imagine une action libre comme un
déroulé au cours duquel plusieurs
opportunités de décider s'offre à nous
une action qui ne fait intervenir aucune
décision de la part d'un individu nous
paraît au contraire pas libre du tout
pour être schématique monsieur x agacé
par son voisin décide d'aller sonner
chez lui pour lui casser la gueule on
imagine que monsieur x a agi librement
et qu'il y ait donc moralement
responsable de son acte parce qu'il n'a
pas agi sous la contrainte parce que
personne n'était là pour le forcer à
agir ainsi parce qu'il n'était pas sous
l'emprise d'une drogue qui rend fou
parce qu'à plusieurs reprises il aurait
pu décider autrement
ça c'est une concession terriblement
naïf de l'action parce qu'on fait comme
si celles ci pouvaient être clairement
délimitée d'abord où l'action
commente-t-elle quand monsieur x lançons
poing dans la figure de son voisin quand
il sonne à la porte quand il sort de
chez lui quand il se lève de son canapé
juste avant quand il décide de se lever
du canapé ou peut-être encore juste
avant quand l'idée de se lever du canapé
survient dans son esprit ou peut-être
encore avant quand l'état de fatigue de
monsieur x ne lui permet plus de
refouler ses pulsions agressives ou
encore avant dans la cause de sa fatigue
dans ses quarante huit heures passées
sans dormir aux urgences à soigner des
patients ou encore avant quand il a
choisi de faire médecine alors qu'il
aurait dû savoir que le métier pouvait
être éprouvant psychologiquement ou
alors encore avant dans l'éducation
familiale puisque son père lui répéter
toute son enfance que c'était médecine
ou rien je vais un baby de bien sûr mais
on comprend tout de même une
délimitation net de l'action et naïve du
point de vue de la chronologie si le
début d'une action peut se confondre
avec les conséquences de l'action
précédente de quelles actions par le ton
si j'ai été contraint à choisir x plutôt
qu y on m'accordera que ce choix n'était
pas libre mais si quelques jours plus
tard j'ai à choisir sans contrôle
apparente entre a et b on aura tendance
à considérer ce choix libre mais
peut-être que la situation qui me
conduit à choisir entre rallumer est la
conséquence du choix knicks cela ne
suffit-il pas à remettre en cause la
supposée liberté de ce choix c'est
l'autre naïveté de cette conception de
l'action elle ne pousse guère qu'une
échelle reprenons notre exemple l'action
de monsieur dick dale et frappé son
voisin est en fait constituée de
plusieurs actions et on peut plonger
dans chacune d'entre elles virtuellement
à l'infini lors de cet incessant
processus sion que l'activité mentale
monsieur x a imaginé se promener avant
de choisir de rester chez soi à ruminer
son agacement pour son voisin imaginez
se promener et constituer aussi d'un
enchaînement d'actions plus ou moins
enchevêtrés les unes aux autres il ya
déjà le fait de sentir l'idée de la
promenade plantée dans la conscience
regardez la fenêtre pour vérifier qu'il
ne pleut pas ce qui anéantirait tout
projet de promenade se rappeler qu'on a
une ampoule au pied évaluer si elle est
trop douloureuse
visualiser un trajet possible puis un
autre se demander si on ne pourrait pas
rentabiliser cette promenade en en
profitant pour acheter du pain se
demander quel boulangerie est ouverte le
lundi consulter ses souvenirs pour
essayer de répondre à ces questions et à
chaque fois on pourrait vous mais encore
davantage
se demander si monsieur x était libre et
donc moralement responsable d'être allé
sonner chez son voisin pour le frapper
cela devrait en théorie conduire à poser
la même question pour les actions qui
précède le coup de poing c'est important
de le souligner parce que face à la
question du libre arbitre on a tendance
à simplifier à tel point qu'on finit
carrément part évité problème on se dit
que plus vils actions comporte deux
décisions ou de délibérations c'est à
dire d'opportunités pour l'individu
choisir plus une action est libre mais
c'est oublier que chaque délibération
est en elle-même une action dont il
faudrait questionner la liberté définir
une action là des limites et c'est d'une
part décidé arbitrairement de son début
de sa fin et d'autre part décidé
arbitrairement de son échelle c'est à
dire de son sens et de l'importance des
éléments qui la composent peut-être
qu'une micro pulsions à laquelle
monsieur x ne peut rien une espèce de
réflexe mentale quasi imperceptible a
jailli effet comme une étincelle
provoquant un cataclysme décisionnel
menant au coup de poing je tiens pour
très crédible l'hypothèse suivante
la plupart de nos actions tiennent à des
facteurs inconscient ou imperceptible
qui oriente notre cheminement et nos
prises de décisions à notre insu car si
on en revient à notre exemple ce qui
fait le lien le passage d'une action à
une autre le mouvement ce qui fait le
tissu de nos décisions c'est évidemment
majoritairement inconscient mais on se
vit comme si au contraire on était
maître de nos actions et ce qui conforte
cette impression c'est une capacité
magique la volonté nous avons le
sentiment 1 que la volonté est libre
c'est à dire qu'on ne peut pas me forcer
à vouloir quelque chose et 2 que la
volonté est à l'origine de lyon c'est
elle qui me permet de décider
la volonté serait ce qui permet à
l'individu d'éprouver et d'exprimer sa
liberté et donc par extension elle est à
la source d'une espèce de capacité à se
transformer pouvoir décider c'est
pouvoir décider de changer ce que nous
sommes en ce sens cette capacité nous
conférait une forme de responsabilité
vis-à-vis de ce que nous sommes de ce
que nous décidons d'être
il suffirait de faire un effort et ce
qui rend possible cet effort c'est dans
cette catégorie psychologique
mystérieuse et bancal la volonté cette
attitude suppose en effet de donner un
statut particulier à la volonté comme si
elle était une capacité la part libre de
toute détermination voir comme une
source inépuisable d'énergie à
disposition de tout le monde en parts
égales
on est prêt à accepter que tout un tas
de compétences qu'elle a des facteurs
extérieurs comme l'héritage génétique ou
l'environnement social mais pour la
remontée on semble faire comme si elle
elle obéissait à d'autres principes tout
le monde aurait la même possibilité de
se [ __ ] un coup de pied au cul et de
se mettre au boulot on voit l'absurdité
d'un tel postulat d'où vient la volonté
n'était elle pas elle aussi au même
titre que l'empathie ou la capacité de
concentration généré organiquement par
un cerveau lui même soumis à des stimuli
venant du monde extérieur n'est-elle pas
au même titre que la confiance en soi
quelque chose qui se développe dans un
environnement favorable on semble ni
cela et faire comme s'il y avait deux
guînes qui cohabitaient en permanence la
ligne qui indique la puissance déployée
par nos actions en cours et la ligne qui
indique la puissance potentielle maximum
l'écart entre les deux renverrait à
notre potentiel en somme on fait comme
si on était que ponctuellement à 100% de
ses moyens c'est un type on se dit
présentement je pourrais faire plus mais
au fond on n'en sait rien on pourrait
très bien être constamment à 100% de nos
moyens ignorer qu'une ligne et notre
puissance évoluerait en fonction de
divers facteurs au piment besoin de
conserver la notion hasardeuse de
potentiel va-t-on considérer par exemple
que le record personnel d'un sportif
correspond à ce fameux 100 % que pour
toutes les autres performances il
n'était pas à son maximum où va-t-on
rencontré à penser que cette puissance
maximum varie selon les circonstances en
même temps il y à cette intuition tenace
selon laquelle on aurait réserve de
puissance à disposition par exemple
juste avant le départ de la course qu'en
est il de la relation du sportif à sa
puissance tels pas là suspendu comme un
potentiel ne demandant qu'à être
déployés n'est ce pas ce qui fait la
particularité de la course eh bien je
crois que ce n'est pas comme ça qu'il
faut poser le problème avant le départ
de la course par exemple on peut
défendre l'idée que les sportifs
déploient pleinement sa puissance qu'il
est déjà à 100 % seulement avant la
course la puissance en question est une
autre puissance que la puissance de
courir avant le départ le sportif
actualise par exemple sa puissance de
concentration de visualisation ce sont
d'autres puissances la puissance de
courir vite n'existe pas en tant que tel
indépendamment d'autres puissances qui
lui sont associés notamment la puissance
de décidé de courir ces bêtes à rappeler
mais si le sportif n'est pas capable de
décider de courir il ne pourra pas
courir être à 100% cela renverrait donc
à une forme d' équilibre un point de
tension entre différentes puissances des
puissances parfois en contradiction les
unes avec les autres
on pourrait être tenté de nous rétorquer
que le sportif peut décider de courir
moins vides mais cela revient au même à
moins de faire de la volonté cette
source mystique et inépuisable d'énergie
liée à la prise de décision une course
moins rapide renvoie aussi à ceux 100 %
à cet équilibre des puissances comme une
mise en tension de puissance contraire
puissance de colo aussi vite que
possible et dans le sens contraire
puissance de retenir sa foulée afin de
s'échauffer sans prendre de risques de
se blesser par exemple donc puissance de
surveiller son rythme etc
on pourrait avoir envie de répondre par
exemple qui n'est pas à 100% de ses
capacités musculaires mais si l'on
s'autorise ce genre de jugement on
bascule dans une autre relation au
concept potentiel qui devient purement
physiologique et n'a plus grand chose à
voir avec le problème de la personnalité
nous confondons la puissance subjective
et la puissance objective c'est une
chose d'avoir des jambes qui permettent
de courir vite encore faut-il avoir la
puissance de vouloir courir vite
encore une fois tout le problème réside
dans l'idée que l'on se fait de la
volonté
si la volonté écoles et cette chose
libre abstraite situés hors de notre
corps alors oui il existe une puissance
potentielle comme suspendu ne demandant
qu'à être actualisée et ça suppose
adopté une position dualiste c'est à
dire que l'esprit est indépendant du
corps ce qui permet de dire qu'il y
aurait quelque chose comme une
personnalité et que ceux ci existent au
delà de ce que je fais au moment où je
le fais mais si la volonté est elle même
une capacité une puissance si elle varie
avec notre état de forme elle l'heure il
n'existe pas de potentiel et nous sommes
sans doute constamment à 100% c'est donc
une conception humaniste l'esprit se
confond avec le corps ce que je suis
n'existe qu'au présent et se confond
donc avec ce que je fais
c'est pourquoi pour en revenir à la
question de la réussite sociale dire
j'ai bossé pour en arriver là revient à
ouvrir la porte à une régression à
l'infini d'où vient cette capacité de
travail cette motivation ce courage
cette énergie vous le sentez ces
questions d'être précisément en ville
répond la volonté pour comprendre la
place que l'on donne au mérite dans nos
vies il faut se pencher sérieusement sur
l'idée que l'on se fait de la volonté
parce que cette notion psychologique à
quelque chose de super en guinée on ne
sait pas bien ce qu'elle désigne sinon
l'expérience très intime un sentiment
profondément personnelle on pourrait
même dire qu'on s'identifie à sa volonté
d'abord parce que ce qu'on veut prend
généralement il place importante dans
nos vies ce qu'on veut c'est ce que l'on
va essayer d'obtenir c'est la source de
notre motivation la raison pour laquelle
on agit on organise notre vie entière
notre quotidien en fonction de ce qu'on
veut et de ce qu'on ne veut pas autant
que possible on essaie d'obtenir ce
qu'on veut et d'éviter ce qu'on ne veut
pas rien que de ce point de vue on
comprend l'importance de la volonté si
tout ce que je fais est plus ou moins
liés à ce que je veux si tous mes choix
sont liées à ce que je veux alors
naturellement je finis par avoir
l'impression que ce que je suis
correspond à ce que je veux c'est le
premier sens dans lequel on peut dire
qu'on s'identifie à la volonté
mais à un niveau psychique encore plus
profond on peut aussi considérer qu'on
s'identifie à la volonté en ceci que
l'expérience de la volonté est un
sentiment de soi quand je veux je me
sens vouloir et donc je me sens existent
et je sens le jeu de jeu veut s'affirmer
vouloir c'est se sentir désiré quelque
chose donc se sentir soi même en ce sens
la volonté est pour celui qu'ils
éprouvent une sorte de manifestation de
sa propre personne
quand je veux quelque chose il me semble
que je ne peux pas me tromper
c'est bien moi qui veux cette chose je
me sens vouloir ce que je veux
il est bien possible que ce soit là
aussi au fond une illusion une partie de
la philosophie de l'esprit contemporaine
se portent là dessus mais à la limite ce
n'est pas mon problème ici ce qui
m'intéresse c'est l'expérience intuitive
communément partagée
de ce point de vue on peut dire que je
ne peux pas vouloir s'en m'identifier à
cette volonté je ne peut pas à la fois
vouloir quelque chose et douter que
c'est bien moi qui vaut cette chose je
peux avoir l'impression de subir la faim
la fatigue un désir vie mais je n'ai
jamais l'impression de subir ma volonté
j'insiste pour souligner à quel point
nous sommes pris dans une relation très
étroite avec la volonté il est
extrêmement difficile de s'en déprendre
de la considérer avec recul comme un
avènement mental qui ne nous
appartiennent répand
alors comme on s'identifie à sa volonté
en toute logique on sent responsable et
ce en deux sens distincts d'abord on est
censé assumé sa volonté si je peux
défendre l'idée que je ne contrôle pas
mes désirs ou mes pulsions en général
c'est beaucoup plus délicat pour la
volonté on pourrait être tenté de dire
que la volonté c'est simplement un désir
conscient reconnu et assumé jeudi
assumer au moins en soit même si je veux
quelque chose alors je reconnais
l'existence de raison de le vouloir je
comprends pourquoi je veux ce que je
veux je peux donc répondre de ma volonté
au moins on voit même je ne débat pas de
ce que je veux l'opposition entre ce que
je veux et ce que je ne veux pas est
très clair lorsqu'on est incertain et
qu'on ait conduit à dire je ne sais pas
ce que je veux nous disons en réalité il
n'ya rien que je veuille vraiment le
deuxième sens dans lequel on peut dire
qu'on se sent responsable de notre
volonté or voilà ce qu'on évoquait
plutôt à propos de l'identification de
la volonté à une capacité c'est-à-dire
que l'on se sent responsable de son
manque de volonté
quand on dit d'une rencontre sportive
serrés que ceux qui l'ont emporté était
simplement ceux qui le voulaient
davantage on essaie d'introduire un
sentiment de mérite et de légitimité
dire ceci c'est dire ils ont gagné pour
une bonne raison il n'y a rien d'injuste
dans cette victoire sous-entendu tout le
monde a même réservé à volonté il suffit
de vouloir personne n'est dépourvu de
volonté nous sommes tous égaux face à
cette source de puissance d'énergie de
motivation gagner grâce à la volonté ne
remet en rien en cause l'équité la
rencontre la victoire est méritée le
sorte qu'on a affaire ici à une
responsabilité morale bien particulière
la responsabilité de sa propre réussite
de sa propre vie l'idée que l'on se fait
d'un concept psychologiques tels que la
volonté peut être déterminant dans
l'organisation de la société
on attribue les récompenses et les
punitions en fonction de ça on rend les
gens responsables de leur succès et de
leur échec parce que l'on considère plus
inconsciemment que tout le monde
bénéficie dans la volonté de la même
source inépuisable d'énergie qu'on est
tous égaux devant la motivation donc si
on ne réussit pas ce qu'on entreprend
c'est parce qu'on ne veut pas assez
réussir autrement dit on est taxé de
fainéantise on valorise le travail et
par conséquent on stigmatise la
fainéantise il faudrait faire une vidéo
à part sur la généalogie des systèmes de
valeurs qui condamne la fainéantise ce
qu'il faut retenir c'est que notre
conception de la réussite est liée à
notre conception de la volonté réussir
sans vouloir c'est avoir de la chance et
on considère qu'il n'y a aucun mérite à
ça c'est assez terrible si réussie aux
dépens de la volonté et si la volonté
d'un trait de caractère alors on est
conduit à admirer ou méprisé des
personnes plutôt que penser que tel
accomplissement ou tel échec et de
résultats d'un ensemble de causes
diverses et variées qui déborde
individus on se met à considérer qu'il
ya des personnes qui valent plus que
d'autres et selon quels critères
estime-t-on la valeur de personnes selon
des critères culturels dont qui
dépendent de la société du lieu et de
l'époque dans laquelle on vit ça sent
pas très juste c'est une position
extrêmement violente au fond et elle
pèse énormément sur nos vies tout le
monde s'inquiète de savoir ce qu'il vaut
de savoir s'il est aimable et tout ça
tient à une conception naïve de l'esprit
ces derniers quand même pour le dire
autrement il faut inverser le terrifiant
quand on veut on peut car en réalité
c'est plutôt quand on peut on veut pour
vouloir il faut déjà pouvoir
pourquoi s'accrocheront autant à ce
couple volonté mérite question trop
difficile pour donner une réponse
définitive mais disons que pour ferrer
correspondait plutôt sur le besoin de
savoir ce qu'on vaut même si c'est une
source d'angoissé c'est aussi une
promesse de plaisir et pas n'importe
lequel un des plaisirs les plus intenses
que l'on connaît le plaisir narcissique
la compétition ils dénient mérite qui
lui est associée sont les conditions de
possibilité de l'expérience de la fierté
si je suis responsable de mon succès
alors je peux être content moi il existe
une situation où je peux être fier de ce
que je suis en somme je peux mais mais
ce délicieux remarqua ça me plaît c'est
moi qu'il l'ait fait
j'appelle ça le paradis noir il
semblerait que nous ayons dû mal à nous
aimer autrement quand nous auto évaluant
nous avons inventé différents critères
pour mesurer notre valeur et donc notre
et mobilité au sens propre on se juge
selon ses critères
et comme il nous est si important de
pouvoir vous acceptez nous mêmes nous
nous accrochons à cette fiction qui
permettant une évaluation censément
juste nous autorise à rêver de ce succès
qui serait synonyme d'amour propre le
mérite et ce qui garantit que notre
réussite tient bien à notre valeur
personnelle
peut-être nous est il très difficile
d'être heureux si nous n'avons pas
l'impression d'une façon ou d'une autre
de mériter ce bonheur pour jouir d'un
succès il faut se persuader que ce
succès est juste donc mérité il faut
penser que ce succès révèle être vraies
valeurs
si nous accrochons les démérites c'est
aussi parce que certaines intuitions
sont particulièrement convaincante
imaginons par exemple deux individus
monsieur x et madame y monsieur x a
remporté l'oscar du meilleur acteur dans
un premier rôle et madame y remporter
l'oscar de la meilleure actrice dans un
premier rôle petite parenthèse je n'ai
pas de respect particulier pour les prix
et récompenses cinématographiques ou
artistique en général je trouve même ça
un peu absurde mais disons que cela
représente une forme de réussite sociale
un oscar c'est objectivement un symbole
de succès et à voir la réaction de
celles et ceux qui le reçoivent c'est
effectivement perçu comme tel par les
premiers concernés bon mettons que
monsieur x est le fils d'un gros
producteurs hollywoodiens ainsi il a
baigné dans l'univers du cinéma de sa
plus tendre enfance il a pris des cours
de théâtre avec les meilleurs
enseignants il a reçu des conseils de la
part des plus grands acteurs l'influent
de son père lui a permis de faire
plusieurs auditions d'enchaîner les
castings jusqu'au jour où enfin il
décrocha un rôle qui lui convenait un
rôle qu'on aurait dit écrit pour lui ce
fut sombre et cloud comme on dit et
finalement le voilà aujourd'hui recevoir
son oscar
madame y quant à elle fut élevée par une
mère célibataire à hoboken dans le new
jersey sa mère cumulait plusieurs
boulots pour joindre les deux bouts elle
a même dû commencer à faire des petits
jobs dès son adolescence pour avoir un
peu d'argent de poche et idées aux
dépenses du foyer du coup elle ne
pouvait même pas intégré la troupe de
théâtre du lycée qui répétait pendant
ses heures de boulot mais dès qu'elle
avait un moment libre elle jouait la
comédie devant son miroir répétées des
monologues imiter des scènes de ses
films préférés
à la sortie du lycée elle pris un bus et
traversa le pays pour rejoindre los
angeles et comme 99% des aspirante
actrice de la ville californienne elle
donne un serveur dans un restaurant et
un tas de participer à des castings pour
décrocher un volant un jour elle fut
retenu pour une publicité c'était un
premier succès puis plus rien pendant
des mois un jour un court métrage suivie
d'une autre période de disette jusqu'à
ce casting où elle fut retenu pour un
troisième rôle dans un long métrage son
professionnalisme lui donna bonne
réputation et le louvre à quelques
portes
un film après l'autre elle se fait une
place à hollywood jusqu'à décrocher le
graal bon et bien là il semble difficile
de dire que monsieur x et madame y ou le
même mérite on a le sentiment très fort
qu'il ya une différence d'amérique entre
les deux comment répondre à sept chiche
il y a plusieurs arguments possibles le
premier consiste à rappeler comme l'âme
y est une exception cela suppose donc de
dire la quasi totalité des gens qui
réussissent n'ont pas eu à surmonter
beaucoup d'obstacles de sorte qu'on est
tenté de dire qu'il n'ya pas de mérite
sauf cas exceptionnel c'est un argument
partiel ça veut rien dire il n'ya
généralement aucun mérite à réussir car
la réussite suppose quasi exclusivement
des parcours facile type monsieur x le
sur nos arguments et plus ambitieux il
consiste à dire que pour toute situation
sociale donnée il existe un ensemble
spécifique de cause si l'on considère la
situation sociale le prisme d'une
citation binaire entre réussites et
échecs on peut distinguer ses causes en
deux catégories il y a d'une part
l'ensemble de ce qui constitue des
forces favorable c'est-à-dire tout ce
qui pousse un individu dans le sens de
la réussite ou du succès en tout cas de
ce qui est considéré ainsi d'autre part
l'ensemble des forces défavorable c'est
à dire ce qui fait obstacle à la
réussite et conduit vers l'échec ces
forces sont de puissance variable la
mère de madame y qui lui offre pour ses
16 ans l ouvrage de stanislas qui c'est
une force favorable une puissance plutôt
modeste quand on la compare à celle d'un
tapis joueurs monsieur x quand son père
eut bien des cours particuliers avec al
pacino
aussi dira-t-on que pour tout succès
social donné il existe un certain ratio
de force favorable et de force
défavorable de diverses puissances
si l'on considère l'oscar du meilleur
premier rôle comme forme de succès on
serait donc tenté de déclarer que
monsieur x et madame grecque obou du
compte ont bénéficié du même ratio force
favorable fort défavorable
cela continue d'être contre intuitif
pourquoi et bien parce qu'on se
représente plus facilement les forces
favorable de monsieur x que de madame y
de quelle force favorable a bénéficié
madame y eh bien peut-être que certains
événements douloureux ont façonné sa
sensibilité d'une certaine manière
peut-être que sa mère lui a montré des
films qui l'ont particulièrement marqué
dès sa plus tendre enfance et que ça a
fait naître en elle un rapport
particulier au cinéma peut-être qu'elle
avait des dispositions cognitives qui la
rendait plutôt doué pour les imitations
peut-être qu'à une époque de sa vie le
cinéma était la seule chose qui pouvait
la soulager de ses angoisses et qu'elle
s'est donc plongé dedans cordiale
notez qu'on parle pas de bonheur ou
d'avoir une vie heureuse ce qui
constitue une force tient à l'objectif
et les forces sont favorables ou
défavorables du point de vue du succès
qu'elle oscars on remarque que cet
argument fonctionne bien avec le
précédent les forces favorables dont a
bénéficié madame y sont tellement
fragile elles tiennent à un tel concours
de circonstances qu'il n'y a rien
d'étonnant à ce que c'est le site soient
rarissimes
pour le dire autrement les forces
favorables dont a bénéficié monsieur x
sont plus faciles à maîtriser c'est à
dire qu'elles tiennent moins au hasard
en cela elles reprennent des inégalités
structurelles
le père de monsieur x pouvaient décider
que son fils joris de certaines forces
favorable c'est ce que permet sa
situation sociale tandis que de l'autre
côté la mère de madame y n'a pas ce
pouvoir pour que malade y réalise son
rêve il faut que les hasards de la vie
s'en mêle il faut tout un tas de
facteurs impondérables et ça nous permet
de retomber sur la notion de justice en
fait ce n'est pas que monsieur x mérite
- son oscar que madame y c'est que son
succès est moins justes ou plus injuste
que celui de malades y prenons un cas
extrême
monsieur x a piraté les votes de
l'académie des oscars et a donc en
quelque sorte volé sa récompense tandis
que madame y l'a reçu en bonne et due
forme là on peut bien dire que monsieur
x ne mérite pas du tout son oscar non eh
bien oui on peut dire qu'il ne le mérite
pas du tout mais ça n'applique pas comme
à la mirec mérite aux siens en revanche
on peut dire que l'oscar de madame y
répondent à certains critères de justice
et d'honnêteté là où l'oscar de monsieur
x est au contraire un cas flagrant
d'injustice et de malhonnêteté cela nous
permet de prendre conscience d'un des
fondements du problème de la notion de
mérite elle repose sur une abstraction
une conception naïve de l'individu elle
fait comme si les individus avaient leur
destin en main c'est à dire comme si on
était censé dominer son environnement
comme si on devait s'extraire de
l'ensemble des forces favorables et
défavorables pour forger tout seul sa
réussite et versa c'est justement un
fantasme de films hollywoodiens si nous
considérons que l'identité d'une
personne est constitué par la somme de
ces expériences par toutes les
influences auxquelles cette personne a
été exposée alors l'idée d'être maître
de son destin devient totalement absurde
la puissance qui pourrait me permettre
de maîtriser mon parcours de vie tient
précisément un ensemble d'événements de
vie que je ne contrôlais pas on peut
reprendre l'idée des forces favorables
et défavorables
ma puissance ma capacité à décider et
agir tout cela ne m'appartient pas car
cela tient à des événements
imprévisibles à des rencontres et ces
personnes mais l'auteur de sa puissance
la question n'est donc pas cette
personne mérite t'elle son succès mais
bien le succès dont bénéficient ces deux
personnes est il juste ce qui suppose
dessous question d'abord d'où viennent
les forces favorables qui ont rendu ce
succès possible si les forces favorables
tiennent à une organisation arbitraire
de la société alors il est difficile de
considérer ce succès comme justes ou
mérité par exemple si on est dans un
pays qui suit un système de castes être
né dans telle ou telle carte déterminera
grandement de possibilités de succès
pourtant personne n'est pour rien dans
sa naissance la deuxième question
consiste à se demander si ledit succès
bénéficie à l'ensemble de la société
mettons que je laisse avec un don pour
les mathématiques et que grâce à cela
j'obtienne un haut poste avec un salaire
très élevé on pourrait dire qu'il n'est
ni juste ni injuste que je sois né avec
ses capacités c'est ainsi on dit parfois
la vie est injuste oui d'accord mais en
fait il faudrait préciser ce n'est pas
la nature qui est injuste la nature est
hasardeuse inégal oui mais pas injuste
elle n'est ni juste ni injuste c'est la
société qui peut être juste ou injuste
que jeunesse avec des capacités qui me
permet d'avoir du succès c'est un fait
du hasard cela ne relève pas de la
justice en revanche la valeur que la
société attribue à mes talents ce que
fait la société de mes capacités cela
relève de la justice ou d'injustice
pourquoi la société me permettrait-elle
de bénéficier de privilèges simplement
parce que j'ai eu de la chance pourquoi
devraient jouir des avantages que me
confèrent mes talons si ceux qui n'ont
pas eu cette chance font face à de
grandes difficultés
c'est quand la société ne corrige pas
les inégalités dues au hasard qu'il ya
injustice c'est donc une autre question
qui est ainsi soulevé avons nous
organiser la société de manière à
limiter l'impact de la chance est-ce que
cela ne semble pas le b à ba de la
justice limiter le facteur chance et
pourtant si on prend le temps d'observer
la société deux secondes on se rend
compte que ce critère minimum n'est
jamais assuré et ce même dans les
domaines qui semble moins suspecte point
de vue
comme le sport vous connaissez la haine
est cher c'est l'équivalent la nba pour
le hockey sur glace comme pour tous les
sports médiatisé des millions d'enfants
américains et canadiens rêvent de
devenir hockeyeur professionnel
si je vous dis qu'un enfant né au mois
de janvier à 4 fois plus de chances
d'intégrer la nhl qu'un enfant né en
décembre ça vous étonne non on a envie
de croire que le mois de décembre ne
joue pas un rôle si important
et pourtant ça s'explique facilement les
inscriptions se terminant le 31 décembre
pour chaque catégorie d'âge de hockey
les enfants nés en janvier est en plus
vieux de onze mois sont généralement
plus grands que leurs coéquipiers plus
grand et donc plus costaud donc souvent
plus fort alors l'on donne plus de temps
de jeu on leur donne plus de conseils
alors ils progressent plus vite alors il
intègre l'équipe une de l'école etc etc
jusqu'à la bourse universitaire
la chance peut intervenir dans la vie de
manière très différente thomas synaeghel
distingue plusieurs types 1 la chance
résultante c'est celle qui détermine les
conséquences de nos actions c'est elle
qui me fait faire un double 6 quand je
lance les dés de la chance
circonstancielle c'est elle qui m'offre
une opportunité d'emploi pile poil au
moment jeu qui peut bien un mois plus
tôt ou un mois plus tard et j'étais au
chômage
3 lachance constitutive qui renvoie à
nos prédispositions à l'héritage
génétique à nos talents et enfin la
chance antécédentes grâce à laquelle
l'étudiant que je suis rencontre sur son
parcours tel prof me permettant de
développer telle compétence pour chaque
réussite que ce soit un prix nobel une
actrice d'un businessman entre vrac sans
difficulté l'intervention de ces quatre
facteurs dans chaque parcours et six
facteurs peuvent être aggravées par la
pétition la société comme on dirait dans
la dernière vidéo naître avec des avants
pour le football permet un statut social
que ne permet pas le talent pour le tir
à l'arc il s'avère que la société
valorise le foot davantage
personne ne mérite sa réussite nous ne
choisissons nino traits de caractère ni
le système de valeurs de la société dans
laquelle nous vivons nous ne maîtrisons
pas non plus les différents facteurs
chance au delà on pourrait être tenté de
dire que tout réussit risque d'être
injuste car s'il ne profite pas au moins
autant à ceux qui n'ont pas eu la même
chance alors elle entérine l'inégalité
qui l'a rendu possible ce serait
confirmée et légitimer une compétition
sociale fondée sur le hasard c'est donc
reconduire un système au sein duquel les
élus les vainqueurs les grands gagnants
seront minoritaires
pour faire accepter une telle société
pour que des populations opprimées
entière acceptent de jouer le jeu d'une
compétition sociale qui leur est
pourtant terriblement défavorable il
faut lui inventer une légitimité il faut
masquer l'injustice mieux il faut la
présenter comme une évidence au point
que sa remise en question même nous
paraissent absurdes c'est ce qu'on nous
présente comme l'ordre naturel
l'élection des meilleurs on ne fait
croire que ceux qui réussissent
réussissent parce qu'ils sont meilleurs
et qu'ils méritent leur compétence ceci
afin de justifier leur accession à une
position de pouvoir alors que la
véritable raison de la réussite tient à
la chance et à une organisation
arbitraire de la société c'était donc
cela en deux mots larnack du siècle
pour résumer l'idée de mérite est fondée
sur une conception naïve de l'être
humain et notamment de sa capacité à
vouloir grâce à la volonté
l'individu rationnelle serait libre et
tout puissant ce fantasme de toute
puissance renvoie à l'idéal d'un
individu capable capable de vouloir donc
capable de décider de changer de
progresser de prendre sa vie en main
capable donc responsable de ses succès
et de ses échecs
cette représentation de l'être humain
devient la mesure étalon et
l'organisation de la société dans son
ensemble pâti de ce fantasme en
légitimant le telle exigence nous nous
autorisons à juger les faiblesses de
certains individus voire à les exclure
des décisions collectives quand il ne
semble pas à la hauteur de cet idéal en
cela le mérite associé à cette
conception naïve de la volonté est une
machine à un justice au nom d'un
individu idéal qui n'existe même pas
nous justifions l'exclusion de celles et
ceux qui ne semblent pas incarner ce
fantasme et c'est pour cela qu'il faut
voir immédiatement la vidéo de patchwork
si ce n'est pas déjà fait elle fait la
généalogie de ce fantasme de l'individu
tout puissant et met en lumière ses
terribles conséquences sur
l'organisation sociale
merci de votre écoute j'espère que ça
vous a plu si vous voulez soutient la
chaîne vous savez quoi faire abonnement
cloche commentaires partage etc allez
salut
[Musique]